this is dharavi
one of India's biggest slums
an intricate network of always
ethnicities and small businesses
a billionaire industrialist is leading a
620 million dollar urban renewal project
here
but residents have concerns
about 40 percent don't have eligible
land records for automatic rehousing
where will they go
and with the U.S short sellers seismic
allegations of fraud at adani group
claims which adani denies will he still
have enough in the tank to redevelop
dharavi
governor madani was not born a
billionaire
he started as a diamond Trader in Mumbai
and made most of his fortune in ports
and Minds he is now one of the richest
men in the world
but adani businesses lost as much as 153
billion after Hindenburg research
published a scathing report detailing
claims of accounting fraud and stock
manipulation
some have called for the adani group's
bid to redevelop dharavi to be canceled
but others remain hopeful
svr srinivas is a top bureaucrat at the
Mumbai Metropolitan Development
Authority which is overseeing dharavi's
facelift
we always thought of Mumbai will be next
Shanghai right but unfortunately it
remained only slumber
if you really want to make Mumbai slum
free the first huge step towards Plum
free Mumbai is dharavi over 1 million
people live in dharavi dharavi is the
world's largest urban renewal project so
the sheer scale and size is something
unseen
there are lot of not just residential
structures but a lot of commercial
industrial structures dharavi is a
thriving economy albeit informal world
so it requires that these livelihoods
need to be protected while the
Redevelopment happens
that becomes extremely extremely complex
Gupta is a social entrepreneur working
to ensure dharavi's Craftsmen have
regular income
she founded an online platform for the
area's residents to sell their products
we are a website and a company that
helps increase the income of Craftsmen
by selling their products online
our basic job is to ensure that they get
enough clients
make a social Enterprise has been
providing skills and vocational training
in dharavi for over a decade
as far as Redevelopment is concerned uh
it's long due and I'm very optimistic
and very hopeful that something good
will come out this time because we've
been hearing about it's in the past 30
years
many residents of the area remain very
concerned about the Redevelopment
project after all this is not the first
time the Redevelopment of dharavi has
been proposed
in 1995 and in 2004 the government of
Maharashtra announced the dharavi
Redevelopment plan which promised free
housing for all of its residents
see earlier projects earlier attempts
were actually if you if I may put it
bluntly they were developer driven I
mean developer will come and he will do
everything right so it entailed two
issues only the entire risk is on the
developer and secondly the residents
were at the mercy of the developer
srinivas believes that the current
proposal is different and will lead to a
future where Mumbai is slum free
so of course there are some concerns
like whether there'll be Justice for All
whether the Craftsmen or whether the
industries will be able to maintain
their livelihoods and maintain the uh
the incomes and the jobs which exist
over here
almost half of dharavi's population do
not have eligible records many may be
forced to leave when the land is
redeveloped into market rate real estate
Abu Bakr makes leather products in
dharavi
foreign
[Music]
the current Redevelopment project
promises free housing for qualified
residents but for workers like abubakar
the future remains uncertain
so there is fear that because of
Redevelopment of dharavi or the
Craftsmen will be scattered a lot of
them might shut shop and go away but
that is what we want to address
adani group has declined to comment
until government approval is granted
meanwhile residents must wait to see
what any Redevelopment may look like
what we've heard uh there is enough
space allocated for commercial
establishments and for rental housing
which is priority because a lot of
people here live on red and a lot of
commercial I mean activity happens over
here so I am very hopeful and optimistic
that if these things happen it's going
to work out
[Music]